[Music]
everyone welcome back to games box 2017
Year in Review we are going to be
talking about PC hardware software and
games and everything between here I'm
here with Jimmy thank you Michael hi I'm
I and I'm like my Hardy let's jump right
into the games start with one of the
bigger exclusives 10 out of 10 on
GameSpot divinity original sent to
Michael did you get to spend a lot of
time with this game which can be
relative yeah so yeah how much time you
can spend with this game ranges from a
hundred to a thousand hours there's so
much in this game it's so dense for me I
played this in a for a party of four
with my friends back home and you know I
I've only got to play it about 20 hours
of it and we're still trying to unravel
the layers and make the character
creation and trying to build these
characters and actually role-playing
this game
divinity original sin to really puts the
role-playing in role-playing game with
all the systems and dialogue and
decisions you can make within these
cities it's the the permutations are
like almost infinite with this
yeah throwback to the computer RPGs in
the 90s right like or even like Baldur's
Gate 2 people are saying this is the
successor to what people always call
like one of the best RPGs if not the
best on the other side of the spectrum
though there's player unknowns
battlegrounds all three of us played it
but Jimmy what's your take on this game
that became this behemoth to say the
least this year yeah so this is actually
my first battle royale game I've been a
Michael Lang we're talking about it
before so to me it feels really fresh
and I always thought for the longest
time that like playing a multiplayer
game I wouldn't be able to to get scared
in a multiplayer game um but I feel like
pop G is actually kind of like a horror
game to me extensive spell like playing
it solo individually I mean it scares
the crap out of game with like somebody
sneaks up behind me so like after a you
know a long session like a 15 20 minute
session where I'm like you know top 10
or whatever and then I get killed I'm
like shaking up oh yeah I get the shakes
I don't you guys experience yeah 100%
oh yeah like I don't know how many
chicken dinners I have at this point I'm
like 56 or something okay
and actually we're not the only ones
that like it broke 20 million in sales
units back in like September October and
it's only more than that now concurrent
users like Steam you're saying it's a
number-one game yeah most plug-in it's
so good it's fun to watch working people
streaming it to say the least but I also
want to talk about a few others before
we get to back to the hardware doki-doki
literature Cup Club just came out
yesterday yes no no no thank you that
game has been out since I think October
sorry I can't get the release date right
but I played it a couple weeks ago a
visual memory it's a visual novel and I
think that you know when you go on Steam
there's so many visual novels on there
that it's almost ridiculous but this one
truly stands out in the way not only it
portrays like anime character tropes but
how it uses those those tropes and those
those character models to tell a very
horrifying story I don't want to get
into the weeds of it and I don't want to
talk about spoilers because this is
something you should really jump into
without any prior knowledge of like what
happens in it but all I really want to
say I wanted to highlight it because
it's a it's a step forward in visual
novels it's something very different and
I think that what it does for the horror
genre is something special I mean I know
you're very much into horror stuff so
I'm be curious to see what you have to
say about it
but for me like when it comes to games
like jump scares whatever zombies is
whatever but something that really
messes with your head is something
special to me and that's what really
gets me this game does it really well
another PC exclusive and playing all
year and I won't talk about too much is
X come to is where that shows an
expansion as any Firaxis expansion
whether it's civilization or XCOM or
anything the Sid Meier has his name on
it reworks the base game just makes it
even better I think like if we were
considering it a game I think ex-cons
who were chosen it's my favorite thing
that happened this year I would want to
talk about ports Jimmy did you play
destiny 2 on PC I did yeah I mean you
probably still are yeah so I had
actually did play this
anyone because I was on the consoles and
primarily a PC gamer yeah I'm gonna
admit and the port's really good I mean
I know Michael you've done a lot of
testing on it everyone's really well
looks great and yeah I can't like
complain about the actual quality of the
board came up yeah Annette yeah so it
was released on battlenet now it's part
of that Blizzard ecosystem it's pretty
crazy but it kind of it makes sense like
what else what other service would it
live on given that activision its
publisher but I mean for me I I think
I'll reserve my own personal opinion of
destiny too but from a technical
perspective I have a fairly mid-range PC
it's pretty old at this point I have a G
I'm running it on GTX 970 which is a
previous generation mid-range car and I
can run that game you know a 1080p
resolution everything cranked too high
and I'm getting consistent 60 frames and
up on that game and it looks great it's
you know even if you're looking out so
the vast vistas or whatever with these
graphics settings cranked up it looks
great it runs well keyboard mouse
support keyboard and mouse support gets
on point and like going I can't go back
to consoles like with the controller any
shooter I have to play with keyboard and
mouse and that game is on point from a
technical perspective as far as other
ports ago we had four to seven which
looked amazing
you know we had resin evil seven again
which was one of my favourite games of
the year we also had neo it came a
little bit after its ps4 debut but we
there were a few bad ports there was a
near automata was not super optimized
Michael do you get the chance to check
that out yeah so I got to I got a chance
to try out the near the PC version of
Nier automata which is and then I went
to the P of ps4 version because there's
a lot of things broken about the PC
version and it still hasn't been patched
to this day I had some sound issues
the controls were I think the
controllers support was broken as well
framerate drops
blank screens and crashes and it's just
like all these little things adding up
and it's I wouldn't want to play this on
PC which is unfortunate because when I
did see the the entire game through on
ps4 it is one of my favorite games of
the year and I really really loved what
yoga taro and platinum did with that
game it's very special to me yeah but if
you do want to play it make
you get the ps4 version at this point
because the PC version is still not
patched Jimmy you get the chance played
pray at all this year I did okay that
also had some game breaking issues that
launched on PC as well it's one of my
favorite games you know what that was
also a little bit broken up PC but so
those are that games pretty much that's
not all of them obviously but that's not
the exhaustive list but I do want to
move on to hardware it was it what was
it was it a big year for hardware and
the PC space Jimmy yeah I would say so
especially in the CPU space we got like
a bunch of new CPUs from AMD and then
like one like sort of new flagship
consumer flagship for from Intel as well
yeah so I did a lot of the CPU reviews
this year okay I got rising AMD's rise
in the series I tested all of them and
the the thing that's special about AMD
CPUs in terms of gaming is that they're
offering more CPU cores for less money
like before I think if you wanted an
eight core CPU we'd have to shell out
almost $1000 to get that now we're
seeing about like $300 for an 8 core CPU
and what that means is that you know
games don't usually utilize that many
cores for the CPU maybe they would use
for it max but what that allows you to
do is do other tasks along streaming
stream yeah you can stream off of one
computer now like super efficiently
without having framedrops because of
like because you don't have enough
processing power and that was really
important for the for PC gaming and then
that also with with AMD coming back and
being competitive because they weren't
competitive in previous years in the cpu
market so that kind of in a way pushes
Intel to you know do something new and
they did they came out with the the Core
i5 and i7 ni threes for the eighth
generation and they added two extra CPU
cores to each one of those so in a way
Intel is also being pushed to add more
value for their CPUs and then you know
who wins
everyone who builds pcs because we're
getting more performance example of like
competition
is good for the market I see these days
there were some neat GPUs as well from
AMD like the RX Vega 64 and 56 yeah you
reviewed those right those are like I
would say mid to high-end cards but
they're really hard to get right now
because of the crypto currency crate is
like driving up all the prices on video
cards in general so you know I get the
question a lot is like is now a good
time to upgrade to a PC or build PC and
I would say yes with the exception of
probably Ram and like the video cards
because the prices on those are pretty
crazy
yeah the crypto creep cryptocurrency
craze and how it relates to video cards
is wild this year man it's like I know
we can you can for a very long time you
couldn't get a video card for MSRP which
is unfortunate for people who want to
build pcs or upgrade and I don't want to
get into like the weeds of what the
cryptocurrency thing was but the fact
the matter is that for PC gamers is that
like man I'm gonna wait out until
there's the prices either go back to
normal or drop for a new generation sure
so that was a little weird and I think
that that was a big story for as it
relates to PC gaming we are talking
about VR separately in another video but
as far as the PC oculus rift HTC vive VR
platforms go Jimmy what kind of year was
it for them on PC so I would say that
for the rift
you had like steady growth I would say
nothing spectacular but you know solve
it all around and I would say that like
coming into 2017 the vibe had the
momentum and kind of lost a little bit
of that both HTC and valve didn't really
do that much in 2017 but we can talk
more about that yeah sure
overall Michael what are your general
thoughts on PC platform 2017 I think
that at least from my perspective I saw
a lot more quality over quantity okay so
in terms of exclusives the ones that
stood out were pub G divinity and
smaller things like doki-doki literature
Club and total more hammer to a total
war Warhammer - really good ideas yeah
so but those are incredible games I mean
we we obviously like multi-platform
stuff is gonna come the PC as well and I
prefer to play them on PC but PC
specifically those games are kind of
like
the standard bearers for what PC gaming
me sure Jimmy what about you what's your
take
yeah I agree with Michael I think we had
you know divinity I just started that
seems really good and I'm just still
really early own pub G I'm still having
a blast that and we got some you know
good ports mostly um so I would say it's
a pretty good year for me to gaming so
here's hoping it continues 2018 that was
PCs 2017 games by Year in Review stay
tuned we'll be doing Nintendo Sony
Microsoft and VR here in our studio
we'll see you then
[Music]